[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
CLAIRE HALLORAN: Today we're
going to do Goodie Bag 4,
VSEPR.
Our objective is to visualize
the three dimensional
structure of some simple
chemical compounds.
The only thing you'll need
is a molecular modeling kit.
A conceptual question you
should think about today
is, what factors determine how
bonds rotate in a molecule?
So the first thing
we're going to do
is draw the Lewis structure
for this molecule.
So we know that Si, S, and CN,
since they have between three
and five valence
electrons, make up
the backbone of this molecule.
And then we're going
to add all of the atoms
around each of these
backbone atoms.
Then counting valence
electrons, we're
going to make sure that
we have the correct number
of non-bonding pairs in bonds.
And this will allow us
to identify the geometry
at each atom in the backbone.
So this silicon bond here
has four bonding domains,
and all of them are
bonded to another atom.
So we know that this is going to
be a test tetragonal geometry.
This bond here, centered
around the sulfur,
has five body domains, and one
of them is a non-bonding pair.
We know that this will
be a seesaw geometry.
And then, finally, this
carbon has two bonding domains
with atoms in each
of those domains,
so this will be a
linear geometry.
And now we're ready
to build our model.
So first, we're going to
draw the Lewis structure
for this molecule.
As with before, we're going
to identify the backbone
atoms in this molecule.
So in this case, the backward
atoms are C, B, and O.
And now we're going to attach
the other atoms to them.
And now we're going
to check and make sure
that there are the proper
number of valence electrons
around each atom.
Next, we're going to
identify the geometry
at each of the backbone atoms.
So the first geometry centered
around this carbon atom here
has four bonding
domains, all of which
contain bonds to other atoms.
So that's going
to be tetragonal.
The second geometry has three
boding domains, all of which
are bonded to other atoms.
So this is going to be a
trigonal planar geometry.
And, finally, the geometry
around this oxygen atom
has four bonding domains, two
of which are bonded to atoms,
and two of which are
occupied by lone pairs.
So that's going to
be a bent geometry.
And now we're ready to
construct our model.
The Goodie Bag 4
worksheet asks us,
whether some different bonds
can be in the same place?
So first, it asks, whether
this H, Si, Si, S, and CN bond
can be in the same plane?
Remember that the CN
bond cannot rotate,
because it's a triple bond.
But we can rotate around this
S, Si bond, and get all three
of the bonds to be
in the same plane.
The plane shown
with my hand here.
So here is our first bond.
Here's our second bond.
And here's our third bond.
All on the same plane.
Next, it asks if we can
have this H, Si, S, F,
and CN bond in the same plane?
And so we can try to
rotate to achieve this.
But we notice that
this isn't possible,
because these two bonds are
always in the same plane,
and we can't get any of
these bonds into that plane,
because of the seesaw geometry.
So for our second molecule
here, the Goodie Bag worksheet
asks a different question.
We notice that this
central CB bond can rotate,
and the Goodie Bag asks,
which configuration
is the lowest energy?
So remember that the
entire VSEPR model
is centered around the idea that
we want to minimize repulsion
between electron
clouds by maximizing
the distance between them.
So we're going to rotate
this so that the repulsion
between these groups in the
molecules are minimized.
So as we rotate this,
we notice that there are
two different possibilities.
Remember that these
green atoms are CL,
and this yellow atom is
oxygen. These are the largest
atoms in our model, and also
the ones that have the most
repulsive electron clouds.
So we're going to
want to maximize
the distance between them.
So one way that
this can be achieved
is by rotating the model so
that the oxygen is aligned
with the hydrogen, which has
a very small electron cloud,
and thus is capable of only
very slight propulsion.
So this configuration
is low energy,
because the very repulsive
chlorine atoms are far
from the repulsive oxygen atom.
However, there's also a
different possibility.
If we rotate, we can put
the oxygen atom in a plane
in between the two
chlorine atoms,
so that the oxygen is not
directly facing an atom.
However, this configuration
puts the oxygen atom
spatially closer to a
chlorine atom, as shown here,
and this hydrogen atom is very
close to this chlorine atom.
So the first configuration
is lower energy.
Today, we used our
molecular modeling kids
to visualize the 3D structure
of some simple molecules using
the VSEPR model.
By playing with these
bonds and rotating them,
we were able to understand
how repulsion between atoms
gives rise to the lowest
energy configurations
of these molecules.